our federal attorneys famous fashion
circus I'm the new dean of the School of
Architecture and planning at MIT and I'm
here to whether we want to be case
conference organized by the castilian
precision program in the School of
Architecture at MIT and I would like to
find the school of architecture and the
separate for art science and technology
for sponsoring this event 100 days and
so do the job I find myself in a
straight position haven't welcome for
you and I p when just this morning I was
still giving worse what country life and
yet if anything can be learning on the
10 units had created in 1964 it is that
the space of time o % the place of
convening and for that perhaps a welcome
back to dialogue is a more fitting way
to something a duty this weekend three
generations of scholars and architects
will be discussing the impact that case
as a stage of dialogue in the native has
had on architecture of education and its
history over the past 50 s allow me
please that instantly dedicate two
minutes to talk about the future of
dialogue among scholars and among is it
would member 2014 at the conference is
longer and into attended and in our
first year together as new teams a lot
of dollars and I quickly got down to
talking about collaboration between
Colombia and mighty but across
universities this far in an increasingly
it's never the playing field not just
behind
across the world and an increasingly
connected and visited net worth of
exchanges of architects and scholars it
is difficult to understand why a paladin
sense of competitiveness and isolation
is growing among schools of architecture
perhaps it is this brilliant narcissism
of small differences that that is
pulling us apart to desperately
distinguish ourselves from each other
but as the case officers have proven it
is the real differences that we should
be seeking to articulate and only
through sustained dialogue and debate
can they be fun it is the real
differences that make us move hospital
and generous perhaps it is my personal
friendship with amount that prompts this
or is it the naive optimism of the new
kids on the block and perhaps you should
be wired where it is to their beliefs
who are putting four piece of dialogue
in the world
but we are moving ahead with this idea
so please stay tuned the convening
capacities and responsibilities of
institutions can only be further enabled
by individual initiatives such as those
taken by HTC factorial over the years
across many generations Stanford and not
just break in the new stuff and I stand
here to thank you for your tenacity in
bringing us together again again and now
as much as I'm honored that it is at MIT
that dialogue is being promoted as the
new zealand house our shared
architecture of the function i'm also
where as changes father stephen
greenblatt has pointed out that the
notion of culture itself including
architectural culture has been
responsible for disguising in typing the
dialogues and exchanges that may capture
happen under the force necessities of
ethnicity spatial fixity and stuff the
crucial first ask for scholars cream
that proposes is simply to recognize and
to track the movements that provoke both
intense pleasure and intense anxiety so
let them the pleasure and anxiety
I've good morning everyone my name is
part of our education issue 3 criticism
section here is the warning before I
begin I would like to mentor to people
who when I program here since they're
both here today and is a unique
opportunity to your single dammam first
of course is Stanford Anderson who
sitting right right here who was one of
the founders along with Hank millen and
Wayne Anderson of the HTC section that
was one of the first PhD programs in
school of architecture in the United
States and professor Anderson one of the
first with a PhD to teach in a school of
architecture and in some sense
transformed the very core pedagogical
orientation of our discipline producing
a program that has produced students
teaching in I think the largest I think
we're ranked as students who teach in
their field in their discipline at I
think ninety-eight percent so it's quite
an accomplishment also we have here
today is Hank melon who's good to see
him and he's also saw him walking by
somewhere there he is and Hank and Stan
have their friendship and their
collegiality their perseverance there is
unique in i would say in this sort of
generation and even in in our generation
and as we're sort of had a sort of
substantial impact on many of us both of
them are our Father figures mentors and
our friends so if i could have a round
of applause please just
so it was a stanch article in the book
second by second modernism MIT
architecture and techno social moment
that was organized by a random that's
sparked is conversational and the
wrentham sort of took took it on to in
some sense think about what it would be
like if we sort of got everybody back
together and so a random gets the credit
for in some sense envisioning this event
and he and other colleagues and Anna
Maria sort of made it made it happen and
I think is going to be an event that
will be partially reunion partially
hopefully ever scattered a discussion
about sort of the pedagogical
imperatives that I think we need to
reevaluate in today's world and
scholarly impact so it has different I
think levels that would be important for
us in various ways but it's important to
also note that many not many but there
are many of up for many of us here that
there are participants in case that or
not here so I just like to briefly
mention them as Michael Graves who
passed away in March twelfth his life
contributions to architecture or well
known and we will remember them then
there's also of course Colin roe whose
voice resonates in our ears for those of
us who know him and Oscar Newman who I
have not met or known but who seems to
have a particularly wry humor from the
way from the photographs I say he
designed a sort of massive underground
thing in New York that looks a little
bit like the matrix City I don't know
that was then there's sort of Bob
slutsky the painter and teacher of love
Legion Giovanni passin Ella who
established the firm p KS b which is
still going strong forty years later so
if you put the names
all these and the names of the entire
case grouped together you have a
remarkable set of people who came
together in the mid-sixties young
creative energetic crying to rethink the
architectural world and ultimately in
small and little ways change it and I
think that there would be some
discussion I think and stands article
there was some question he raised you
know how impactful was case and you know
I think that first some people said well
maybe not enough maybe too much we can
sort of address that but I think it's
quite clear that it's sort of
dissemination sparked changes that took
place sort of far afield we might not so
see a one-to-one relationship but
there's definitely a sort of a oh you
know when to 11 to 21 25 somewhere out
there in the world sort of this sort of
network of relationships that make this
important and that's why we're visiting
case i think is a good thing for us to
do or it's not only a window into
something that took place in the in the
60s but it's also a window perhaps even
into what we have today the sort of
intelligent and open ended conversations
sometimes look discussing things that
today we sort of find a little hokey we
go why are we not talking about those
things anymore so there was a call for
an architecture as the site of sort of
discursive and theoretical speculation
that I think in our over structured
academic world might sound quite
refreshing there is a call for an
architecture as a site of a certain type
of spatial imagination but I think in
our over structured academic world of
today I think we'll also sound
refreshing so look forward to the
conversation thank you very much
push it to the side
there's no effort here
hi good morning thank you for joining us
so much my name is anna-marie and i own
a PhD candidate and MIT is history
theory and criticism of architecture and
art program and i'm here to give you a
big sort of broad view an introduction
to case the conference of architects for
the study of the environment our story
begins in 1964 one year later le
corbusier swam to his death in the
Mediterranean and the first US combat
troops arrived in vietnam two years
later two years later after the
beginning of our story to canonical
books on the city were published at the
same time robert van tories complexity
and contradiction who he mentions in the
first case meeting as a little book that
he's having out soon quite easy to write
and Al Davos is l'architecture Adela
cheetah yet Rossi's book would not be
published in English until nineteen
eighty-two thanks in no small part to
the agency of Peter Eisenman and with
the translation by Joe Nachman and Diane
Gerardo and Peter and John Edward here
with us today I mentioned this curious
at temporalities versi in the United
States to highlight that in many ways is
a very local story an english-speaking
story affected very directly by the
events and the conversations happening
in the United States at this time one
year later before the beginning sorry
one year before the beginning of our
story Martin Luther King jr. spoke by
the steps of the Lincoln monument john f
kennedy was assassinated and penn
station was demolished our story begins
the year bernard Rudovsky road of
architecture without architects and the
year lyndon johnson signed the civil
rights act a piece of legislation
developed according to Malcolm X in
response to the fear generated by
african-american riots the case meetings
are situated geographically close to
these events but far away in terms of
race and income if you pay attention you
can hear a bit of the echoes of what's
going on in the country in their comfort
patients just like the events happening
in the US right now might inflict hours
I mentioned these events to highlight
the time and the place in which case
took place this story is set in the
United States and in many ways it is a
local story as i said before of a group
of young architects in their early 30s
most of them as many of the students
that are here today starting their
careers in a moment when the CM had
ended its 1959 and Lucroy [ __ ] is at
the end of his career and modern
architecture has become an away the
language to of authority the various
already being called into question by
the events of the late 60s it is a
moment with enough temporal distance
from the start of the modern movement
and geographical distance from europe to
prompt the horizon man what Peter Iseman
would propose as a reformulation a
search for new directions in
architecture that respond to this
distance from Europe his origin of the
modern movement and to a different
socio-political moment so I'll now give
you a summary of the case meetings from
1964 to 1974 you can have a broad view
of the events that we intend to discuss
in this conference with special emphasis
on the first meeting and I can do this
thanks to the recent essay events by
Stanford Henderson which has already
been mentioned and if you haven't read
it already you can download it from our
website or by the book and to the
generous access to his archives as
Secretary of case to the participants of
this conference so another way to
describe these ten years we're about to
examine is to say they covered the
distance from this proper young fellow
to this school and collect the gentleman
so in order to introduce today's
discussion as I said I'm going to place
special emphasis and first two meetings
and thanks here go to Kenneth Frampton
who found the tapes of the first
princeton meeting in 1964 and generally
made them available the summer of
nineteen sixty-four several architecture
academics met in cranbrook for the AAA
acs a conference shared by Lawrence
Anderson also head of MIT architecture
to discuss the teaching of history
schools of architecture the proceedings
were published as quote the history
theory and criticism of architecture
unquote through European speakers
generated a lot of discussion brunettes
heavy from Rome argued for historians
who take over the direction of schools
of architecture and Reyner Banham from
London argued the affliction of
architecture was symbolism rather than
utility he was confronted by Stanford
Anderson recently hired at MIT who
challenged venoms position as scientific
determinism also in the conference one
woman Sybil moholy-nagy Henry millen
also from MIT Colin row from Cornell and
thinner ice ax men from Princeton
following this meeting eisenmann
contacted some of the attendants and
other young architects and teachers with
the idea forming quote a critical
apparatus to discuss issues crucial to
the development of a future architecture
unquote with his Princeton colleagues
Michael Graves from Tom timberland I
Simon convene a meeting that will later
became known as case one among the
attendants Colin row Hank melon and San
Anderson Richard Meier practicing in New
York Jack Robertson and Vincent Scully
at Yale robert venturi in philadelphia
and recent london arrival can at
Frampton so recent he had to fly by
helicopter from JFK to Princeton to make
the meetings so we need to always
remember that job eisenmann started the
meeting by marking the distance with the
first generation of Modern architects in
a sense he said one of these problems is
what we have is that we have not had a
modern architecture in this country as
it was defined in Europe 30 years ago
now perhaps we have not had a modern
architecture because we did not have the
same problems that they had rather
because we chose to ignore them but I
think today these problems have become
Universal if in the 1930s the problem
was revolution eisenmann now found the
problem was one of reformulations and he
continued all of us here are architects
and teachers and as such we have already
taken on a rest
ability and all the bolts in the East
quotes are mine I don't think we're
politicians and I don't think that were
flag wavers I don't believe in flag
waving because I don't think that its
architects this is our job however I
think that ever architecture and our
teaching is to have any meaning then we
must be willing to find some direction
for this work therefore we must concern
us ourselves this weekend with the
beginning with a reformulation of
principles about a future architecture
and what these principles of this group
can do for this future he was followed
with someone opposing views and
architectures relationship to the public
from two English historians Kenneth
Frampton and Colin robe Frampton
paraphrased Aldo van I in arguing for an
architect oriented to the masses if
arkitekter have had formerly served
princes and priests it must now respond
to new cultural realities by redefining
itself into new roles roles he concluded
that may be more modest Rao cantered
this position and sort of amazing in
listening to the transcripts to hear
Cohen row give an impromptu answer that
reads like a small essay and every sort
of paragraph has a topical idea just you
know one can hope row counter this
position by arguing that the public had
long been used to justify different
architectural discourses and warned that
the very nature of modern architecture
promoted certain fantasies fantasies
that it was someone's dirty to reveal
one being the fantasy of the architect
or a savior and Messiah and the other
modern architectures and irreconcilable
aspirations to order within continuous
change they were in turn both countered
by a practitioner by robert venturi who
argued for the architecture as a doer
whose speculation and talking must
relate to making and doing as opposed to
an intellectual is interested in ideas
and direction alluding to the preceding
speakers with the idea of ideas and
direction and close with a quote by TS
Eliot on the interrelation between
criticality and creativity to defend the
idea that of the architect as someone
whose ideas and direction on intended
because these were inclusive and sort of
letter calling them together are related
to working and doing Richard Meier
agreed and put forward the housing
situation in Harlem as the kind of
architectural problem they should
address in this aspire this is the kind
of problem in which we as individuals
concerned with the future of
architecture must be actively involved
in which we take the responsibility for
making proposals that confront the
unresolved dialectic of the urban
condition to build architecture has to
do with the attitude with which we
confront the existing power structure
which will influence the future of
architecture michael mcconnell agreed as
a fellow practitioner and then tim real
an elegantly picked up under all the
previous threats to argue for a
rethinking of architectural education to
prepare architects not only for the
problems of mass housing but also for
the pragmatic challenges of practice
viewed as both fantasy and reality a
recurring theme through the weekend and
I apologize for my crude
characterization of everybody here which
will show up in different forms in other
meetings was that that of the architects
creativity and on ways to better
understand the creative impulse and
finally City Planning was a contested
issue Jack Robertson involved in New
York City Planning spoke of the
perception of Architects in essential in
society and advocated and involvement in
policymaking Vincent Scully defended
architecture against planning to Hank
melons opposition and lamented
evaluation of the past the group decided
to meet again and then to reset goodbye
I won't go into the fool two days worth
of sessions in 1964 we have incomplete
information and not all the speakers are
identified in the recording besides we
hope to discuss some of these recurring
topics in the group's meetings
throughout the day in listening to the
transcripts we can see there was a
spectrum of critical positions as to the
discipline and its role some more
complimentary and flexible and others
quite firm in their determination to
keep their distance attention between
practice and reflection
an interest in collaboration stood in
various different ways from the
potentially fruitful discussion of ideas
or projects to the more pragmatic
mobilization of a group itself for the
promotion for promotion in order to
secure individual jobs we since the
architects are aware of the advantages
provided by the idea of a group
particularly when allied with a polemic
ID or manifesto to gather attention but
to what effect and how to maintain the
balance between their own disagreements
and the common front needed for a
group's identity these discussions will
reappear throughout the life of case so
quickly take you through the following
meetings case to was in nineteen
sixty-five and it was convened by
Anderson Isom and Frampton graves and
millen to discuss the sign and criticism
as interdependent activities you see how
they are picking up on some of the
threats already the group called itself
case and designated Anderson as
executive secretary and I Simon and
Frampton as quote ad hoc committee on
bylaws unquote and established a series
of study groups it's interesting to
compare in the ten issues listed in the
foundation statement to Anderson's notes
on the committee's and their members you
can see his notes above and then the
clean to the version below the list
reflects the diversity of interest in
the group but paradoxically seems to be
in reverse order to the importance of
their main concerns so if we go through
it the last topic there below is
education and architecture that's the
last of the list that you see most
people have signed up for that and then
we have history in criticism which of
course has all the historians and then
we have form a sort of a more proactive
mobilization of creativity with a big
group signed up but then for creativity
itself it's a smaller group it's the
discussion between millen and Anderson
and then psychology of the architect
including his guilt complexes and those
like unrevealing of the fantasies that
only has rope right here we have
architecture and its political structure
with Robertson and pass on Ella and
architecture another this
lens has a very lonely Meyer their
technological innovation has graves and
Anderson and industrial techniques has I
cannot read that who's there so what
else um Newman okay oh no one okay sorry
so it's just and this was a mark sort of
highlighted this in the last time we
discussed this how these issues that are
sort of at the forefront for some
discussions who they didn't have as much
interest back in the day and then up
first we have the city and mass
phenomena including its ethnic and
racial problems with Frampton mairon
Braves so the magazine oh and the
magazine group is also full first here
journal although that project would be
over by the end of the year he's three
and four took the form of symposiums at
MIT case three was organized by Anderson
and melon who had called on
distinguished academics and disciplines
outside architecture but the resulting
discussions left case members feeling a
little left out prospective members
attended and were invited to join
including Robert slutsky and online
Linden grace and Meyer organized case
for as a conference title in a critical
approach to urban form this is here the
event was successful but indicative of
the group's problems the great diversity
of interest and introspective nature of
the meetings Linden proposed a solution
to both problems by having case members
invade a school of architecture for a
week the group would focus on education
as their common theme and project itself
towards a larger architecture community
oh my yes here so in 1967 case members
did just add by organizing a teaching in
oregon linda the school and we'll hear
more about that in our second panel but
the event included several invited
guests
among which I want to highlight doorway
Vinson of history of architecture in
Oregon and doors Hayden and here we have
some of the schedules here these members
also worked in school teams for the moma
a new city exhibition presenting
projects for different sites of Harlem
as I chosen by our third Drexler
director of the department of
architecture and design at MoMA and I
Simon and we'll hear more about the
recurring theme of the city city
planning and city politics in different
iterations throughout case in our first
panel also sorry i passed myself here
also in 1967 MIT students demolish the
studio walls ideas and build best names
over a weekend and in New York Peter
Eisenman created the Institute for
architecture in urban studies and around
this time case members is agreed to
split into city groups to such case
meetings were convened in 1969 one in
Boston by Anderson who led a workshop to
design and build an exhibition at MIT
and organized a meeting for the
exhibition in 1969 and images from that
and one in New York a meeting organised
at MoMA and co-sponsored by I by the ia
us and New York case and we can see here
some of the guests which include
rustling Krauss I find it interesting to
see also that in the schedule Anthony
early who cannot join us today is
discussing the dilemma of type and I
particularly enjoyed the disclaimer here
I'll read it for you case unfortunately
we'll only be able to provide
intellectual simulation for this
particular meeting transportation
accommodations and meals will be the
responsibility of each person attending
the sessions I'm going to remember that
for ok so in 1971 case 8 was organized
by case New York the conference was
organized around Rouen schlotzsky's
transparency essay with new guests
including George paired rustling Krauss
in Anthony viddler and I really just
wanted an excuse to use this picture of
Anthony viddler we can see how these
events led to the five architects
exhibition at MoMA after that the IUS
took over with the participation of some
case members and here's the team in the
Casa Bella coverage of the group I Simon
and Frampton edited the IUS journal
opposition's well Anderson focus on a
new project is taking shape at MIT the
formation of the first PhD program in
the history of architecture eventually
in the form of the history theory and
criticism of architecture and art group
or HTC we're very happy to be your host
today in discussing the group its
members have agreed to disagree eisenman
has described it as a rather ugly child
it will form then without direction
direction Anderson has said its
diversity it might be both the reason
for its demise and the source of
inspiration towards new projects
Frampton has focused on the difficulty
of finding an area of true agreement I
finished perhaps with the voice of
Colleen row who in the first meeting
pointed out that often disunity and
disagreement might be more productive
than a willingness to get along so what
happened to case did it benefit from
this productive disunity yes row put it
was this energy the source of both its
success and eventual the solution with a
publication as opposition state later
have helped balance the different
interest of the group and broadcast them
outside it's a combined model of
practice and academia group still viable
today when they seem increasingly
separate can practicing architects meet
with professional historians when
specialization seems to pull them
increasingly apart perhaps her panelists
and moderators will address some of
these issues for the purposes of today's
event we decided to organize the
conversation along three main topics
that provided inspiration discussion an
action for the members of case the city
introduced by Deepa ramaswamy activism
and interdisciplinarity introduced by
Jessica Varner and the tension between
formal autonomy and historical precedent
introduced by ricks vostra Deepa Jessie
Kendricks will give you a brief
introduction
to the political cultural and
architectural context that surrounded
these discussions into the main issues
at stake we will then ask her panelist
and moderator to come to the stage for a
conversation and after each panel will
finish with an opportunity for question
it's an answers from our audience we
will conclude with a keynote discussion
on the links I divergences between case
and I aus preceded by a short
presentation by john ottman before I see
the podium to deeper for our first
introduction I want to take a moment to
thank a few institutions and people that
have been key in the organization of
this event revisiting case is organized
by the HTC program and funded by the MIT
Center for art science and technology
and by the MIT department of
architecture thanks go out to our
interim director of HTC meet indian head
of the department we lack any executive
director at cast and toured in Hashem
Sarkis for all their support very
special thanks to end of oh and cake
barely who provided the structure and
support that keeps HTC running deeper
ramaswamy Jessica Varner and Rick's
whatcha who will be introducing our
panels today it is not jenya cove at MIT
publications for her fantastic support
in printing and promotion and for her
collaboration assembling some relevant
case materials upstairs at Keller
gallery please walk by as you as we
break for lunch we invite you to visit I
also want to thank Barker recent MIT
graduate for the wonderful past poster
and our team of HTC assistance and
volunteers Saturn echo vicario Albert
Lopez cristiana Bonin Sarah burger human
Gupta evoker Massey Carolyn Murphy and a
hurry up please join me in thanking all
these individuals and institutions for
their generous support
you
you